okay so kanye west held a presidential
campaign speech in south carolina where
he had
a full-on meltdown because he said that
harriet tubman
didn't free the slaves that she actually
just gave them away to other oppressive
white people interesting and he also
talked about
um the female's choice to
decide whether to abort a child or not
by saying that he didn't want
kim to keep his daughter and he started
crying saying
i was going to kill my daughter and this
is the clip
so he's off the medication
dude he is not doing well
[Music]
you know what i don't believe that i
don't like seeing that well you know
what he's having a meltdown he's off
medication beat i don't believe one word
of
it okay as soon as you got pregnant i
guarantee wasn't like oh we gotta you
have an abortion kim kardashian's like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
hey that never happened b he's off
medication was he wearing a bow-proof
vest
he was wearing a bulletproof security
he's not he's he probably shouldn't be
run for president do you think
that was the first press conference yeah
that didn't go well
that did not go well i i sometimes i
think america he realized he couldn't
yeah i think he did get on a ballot
somewhere
but he realized that he was too late he
couldn't get on the ballot in florida i
think it was like ah [ __ ]
dude that's that's very scary it's very
scary it's very alarming
he's crying and freaking out well he's
just he's mentally ill brad
yeah go kill dogs with them
god damn man that's sad i don't like
seeing that i don't like seeing and
somebody melt down like that
i know i hate when i see billionaires
freaking out no that's that's no joke
but also but it's that's kanye west all
right i
i didn't realize people have way bigger
problems man i don't think i realize he
really had mental illness
are you kidding me yeah dude you never
seen him pop off before no
he did he got put into insane asylum
makes cool shoes really tallonious monk
who was one of the greatest
jazz pianist he started
like he was a genius and his he's
and you can see it on there's actually a
video of it he would start
kind of walk twirling in a circle just
started
like a ballerina just would kind of
start twirling and talking
to himself and he slowly just went crazy
he didn't talk to him well he didn't
really talk to himself he just
that's that's a what is that a manic
episode or something
he's freaking out man i still think he
realizes he's in over his head trying to
run for press in the united states i was
like
ah because people ask him real questions
like gun laws and pandemics and [ __ ]
inflation and stocks and the market and
he's like
uh what the [ __ ] a little bit more
interesting i was gonna kill my daughter
though
the [ __ ] he just you know oh yeah it's
funny
when he comes to me i know somebody was
crazy who ran for president
and then i i was like and then my friend
said did you see what happened we were
eating
and she never took her gum out of her
mouth and she had a whole meal i swear
to god
see i call that talent i know i do too
she's eating a salad
and my friend said did you notice that
she never took her gum out whoa
and then she ended up being crazy well
crazy is a
i don't know what that word means but
mental she had mentioned crazy cool yeah
oh yeah connie's not doing well i i have
i'll tell you
but but you also gotta you have to think
about the kardashians too it has to be a
little i mean
they're around him all the time so you
know
see what what the [ __ ] going on what's
the what's the family dynamic like you
know it's
so strange man i'll tell you a story
off here i don't know if i can tell it
on there okay about mental illness about
my experience with somebody who
i dated who had and it ended badly for
her you know
anyway guess i want to hear that story
yeah i'll tell you later
she died i don't want to be just did she
follow her memory did she die yeah
oh definitely don't want to hear it yeah
tell us about killing dogs
no i just think mental illness is so
serious and and we don't know anything
about it we don't [ __ ] know anything
about it man and so when you
a guy like that like who has everything
and has a manic episode like that i
really hate seeing that [ __ ] [ __ ]
but he also thinks when he takes
medication it limits him
creatively so he stopped his medication
you know so there's that
that makes sense maybe you know that's
what they say i don't know
but you think kim kardashian the rest of
family is like dude what the [ __ ]
yeah hang out this guy all the time you
realize having to live with that it's
like
it's like when you hear so i have one
experience with alcohol like real
alcoholism where
you see somebody when they get drunk and
some people they're really nice and they
start drinking and they get
nasty more than nasty they become
terrifying
yeah i saw that once and uh it was
it was the father of somebody i knew
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah
i mean i saw my friend i went oh that's
why you don't talk to this person yeah
he goes oh no you have no idea i went oh
now i have an idea i had no idea
so i don't know man i'm gonna tell you
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected